اهلا بكم مشاهدينا في اخبار الساعه من
العربيه نستعرضون معكم ابرز المستجدات وفي
العناوين
موسكو وكيف تتبادلان القصف والجيش
الاوكراني يتهم روسيا بنصف سد ثاني
امام المحكمه الفيدراليه بتهم جنائيه
وتعزيزات امنيه للتعامل مع اي احتجاجات
امريكا تحذر من تخريم الكتروني صيني
لبنيتها التحتيه وتستخدم دبلوماسيه لابطاء
قوه بكينا العسكريه
اول مشروع قانون لتقنين
استخدامعي امام البرلمان الاوروبي اليوم
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا اعلنت الشرطه
البريطانيه انها تتعامل مع حادث خطير
ومستمر في مدينه نوتنهام
جاء ذلك تزامنا مع اغلاق عهد من الشوارع
ووضع خدمه الطوارئ في حاله السنفار مع
انتشار كثيف للاثار الشرطه كما تمت مطالبه
السكان بالبقاء بعيدا عن منطقه الحادث
مشاهدينا من لندن معنا هاتفيا مراسله
العربيه مستفزه اهلا بك مصطفى وماذا يحدث
في نوتنهام
حقيقه بحسب ما جاء في بيان لسوبر انه تم
اغلاق العديد من الشوارع في وسط مدينه
نوطغام اثناء التحقيق في مسمته بحادث كبير
يتم التعامل معه من قبل عناصر الشرطه
وايضا شهدت العديد من مركبات خدمات
الطوارئ بالاضافه الى ان الشرطه ناشدت
الناس ومستخدمي المركبات بتجنب هذه
المناطق هذا الاغلاق لعدد من الطرق في في
اخبار ان تم اغلاق على الاقل سته شوارع في
وسط المدينه مما اثر على خدمات القطارات
في وسط المدينه وايضا حافلات النقل حتى
هذه اللحظه الشرطه لم
تدعم طبيعه هذا الحادث لكن بحسب تقارير
اوليه بانه يتم تقديم اسعافات اولياء لشخص
على على على جانب من هذه الطرق التي تم
اغلاقها وبالطبع
يعني بحسب المشاهد التي تم نقلها حتى الان
العديد من عناصر الشرطه متواجدون في هذه
المناطق بالاضافه الى سيارات وحافلات
يعني الاسعاف بالاضافه الى الدفاع عناصر
الدفاع المدني بطبيعه الحال كل كل ما كل
ما اشاهده حاليا وهو فقط
خدمات الطوارئ في
الشوارع لكن الكل يتساءل يعني سبب هذا
الاغلاق بهذا الحجم حتى في وسط المدينه
وفي ذروه يعني التنقل في في البلد وبالطبع
الكل يترقب ما هي طبيعه هذا الحادث هل هو
يتعلق مثلا يعني
بحدث يعني
عرضيه اما انه ربما هناك حادث يجب يعني
التعامل بشكل
حازم خاصه في في ظروف استثنائيه تشهدها
البلاد بالطبع الكل يعني يريد معرفه
المزيد لكن حتى هذه اللحظه الشرطه
لم تعلن عن طبيعه هذا
الحدث له دوافع تتعلق بجرائم او ارهاب وما
الى غير ذلك وبالتالي يعني نحن بحاجه الى
مزيد من
ربما سيتم تقديم بعض المعلومات في وقت
لاحق ما يعني بطبيعه يعني حاليا اشاهد
يعني مشاهد من وسط المدينه ليس هناك
من المشاه ليس هناك اي مشاهد للناس في وسط
هذه الماده فقط عناصر الشرطه متواجدون
وهناك اشر يعني لاغلاق هذه الشوارع
بالاضافه الى
[موسيقى]
يعني مختلف المركبات وخاصه تلك التي
تتعامل مع الحرائق لا ادري ان كان هناك
حريق ضخم في هذه في هذه المنطقه
هناك مصطفى شح كبير في المعلومات لكن هل
من الطبيعي او المعتاد ان تتعامل شرطه
بريطانيه بهذا الشكل مع مثل هذه
الحوادث اعني هنا التكتم على طبيعه هذا
الحدث ومطالبه السكان في ذات الوقت توخي
الحذر من امر مجهول بالنسبه لهم في
المواطنين بالتاكيد
حدثت يعني
حوادث مشابهه لما شاهدناه يعني اليوم وما
نشاهده اليوم في مدينه
نوتنغام لكن
بالطبع
ستكون هناك بعض القراءات الاوليه في طبيعه
هذا الحادث ولكن بسبب تكتم الشرطه يعني
ربما يزيد من التكهنات حول طبيعه هذا
الحديث وبالتالي لربما سنسمع
التفاصيل حول هذا الحديث قريبا وخاصه وان
كل الانظار الان تتجه الى هذه المدينه
الواقعه في شمال انجلترا والتي تبعد
بحوالي ساعتين بالقطار من وسط من من وسط
مدينه لندن طيب كيف يمكن توصيف الحاله
الامنيه في نوتنهام مصطفى قبل هذا اليوم
هل هناك ما يمكن ان نستشف منه طبيعه ما
يحدث الان في هذه المدينه
يعني
منذ اكثر من 20 عام ولكن هذه الحوادث عاده
ما تكون
يعني ما نشهدها ونشاهدها في المدن الكبرى
مثلماشيستر
مثل لندن وبيرمنغام وحتى غلافو ولكن مدينه
ماتي هي مدينه يعني ليست
بالكبيره مقارنه ببقيه البدن يعني لكن
الكل يعني في حقيقه
لغز يثير فضول الكثير من الناس خاصه
الصحفيين الذين يريدون ان معرفه يجري هناك
في هذا الوقت الحالي يعني هذا الحادث وقع
تقريبا قبل اقل من ساعتين من الان ولا
تفاصيل دقيقه حقيقه ما يجري هناك لكن
بالطبع الشرطه
ستعلن عن
التفاصيل فيما يجري حاليا هناك طيب
الاعلام البريطاني ربما يكون اشد قربان
يعني من قياده الشرطه او مراكز صراع
القرار في بريطانيا كيف يتعاطى مع هذه
الاحداث حاليا ما الذي تنقله قنوات
الاعلام حاليا في بريطانيا
قلت قبل قبل قليل انها ليست هناك معلومه
دقيقه هناك اخبار
بحسب بحسب هذا البيان الذي نشرته الشرطه
واي تحليلات بخصوص ما يجري على الارض
حاليا
يعني حتى مثلا القناه الرسميه البي بي سي
لم تت مع هذا الحادث من بدايته يعني يعني
تم الاشاره الى الحادث يعني في
يعني
تنقل هذا الخبر حاليا وليست هناك تفاصيل
ما جرى وما يجري حاليا في هذه المدينه طيب
من جديد في سياق متابعتنا الان في
ونتابع مشاهدينا معكم هذه الصور من محطه
القطارات وشرطه الوطنيه التي اغلقت بعض
الشوارع والمقر في في نوتنهام نذكر
مشاهدينا بان الشرطه البريطانيه تقول ان
انها تطالب المواطنين بالبقاء بعيدا عن
مناطق الحادث في نوتنهام وشبكه الترام في
نوتنهام بريطانيا تعلق خدماتها بعد
الاعلان عن حادث خطير مستمر والشرطه
البريطانيه ايضا مشاهدينا تستنفر اجهزه
الطوارئ وتغلق عدد من الشوارع كما نشاهد
الان في هذه الصور قوات الشرطه وعربات
الاسعاف التي انتشرت ايضا في مناطق مختلفه
في نوتنهام
مازلنا معكم مش في انتظار المزيد من
المعلومات حول ما يحدث في هذه المنطقه
التي تتكتم السلطات البريطانيه او الشرطه
البريطانيه عن ما يحدث فيها حيث تقول انها
تتعامل مع حادث خطير في نوتنهام
ونذكر ايضا بان مراسل العربيه قبل اتحدث
عن ان مناطق وسنه هام اصبحت معطله بالكامل
بسبب طوق امني واسع والشرطه البريطانيه
ايضا يقول العربيه انها لم تكشف حتى الان
عن تفاصيل الحادث الامني وسيارات الاسعاف
والاطفاء واجهزه الامنيه ايضا رفيعه
المستوى موجوده في
مصطفى دعني ابدا معك من هذه النقطه
الاخيره التي اشرت اليها في سياق ما تفضلت
به حول مشاركه اجهزه امنيه رفيعه المستوى
ما طبيعه الامن المشارك ايضا في متابعه
تفاصيل هذا الحادث وما الذي يمكن ايضا ان
نستشفه عن مدى خطوره الوضع الامني الان في
المدينه عاطفا على مشاركه هذه الاجهزه
مع مصطفى
الاتصال مع الزميل مصطفى زاهرون نعود
مشاهدينا ونذكر مره اخرى بان انه نتابع
معكم هذه الصور من نوتينغهام البريطانيه
حيث ان مناطق واسعه في هذه المدينه اصبحت
معطره بالكامل بسبب طوق امني واسع وقد
اعلنت مشاهدينا الشرطه البريطانيه انها
تتعامل مع حادث خطير ومستمر في مدينه
اطنهام وسط انجلترا وذلك مشاهدينا جاء
تزامنا مع اغلاق عدد من الشوارع ووضع
خدمات الطوارئ في حاله استنفار مع انتشار
كثيف لافراد الشرطه وتمت ايضا مشاهدينا
مطالبه السكان بالبقاء بعيدا عن منطقه
الحادث مدينه معكم مشاهدينا في انتظار
مزيد من المعلومات ونتابع هذه الاحداث في
نوتنهام مع التكتم الشديد الذي تفرضه
السلطات البريطانيه على ما يحدث في هذه
المدينه لكنها تقول
ان التعامل مع حادث امني خطير ومستمر وقد
اغلقت سته شوارع الاقل في النوتنهام
مراسله العربيه كان معنا قبل قليل واكد ان
مناطق واسعه او في وسط نوتنهام اصبحت
معطره بالكامل بسبب طوق امني واسع وقال
ايضا ان الشرطه البريطانيه
لم تكشف حتى الان عن تفاصيل الحادث الامني
في نوتنهام نعود مره اخرى مشاهدينا الى
مراسلنا في لندن مصطفى اهلا بك مصطفى هل
من تفاصيل جديده وايضا اعيد سؤال الذي
اشرت اليه قبل قليل حول اما يمكن ان نتشفه
عن خطوره هذا الحاجز من مشاركه الاجهزه
الامنيه التي وصفتها برفيعه المستوى في
متابعه تفاصيل ما يحدث
بالمقارنه بحوادث تابعتها وغطيتها لقناتها
العربيه والحدث يعني هذا الحجم يدل على
انه
هنا يعني
حوادث الارهاب مثل ما شاهدناه في في
مانشستر عام 2017 مثلما شهدناه ايضا في
مدينه غلاسكو منذ فتره بالاضافه الى
مشاهدناه من احداث يعني وقعت في لندن
واخيرا واخيرا هذه الحوادث كان ايضا عام
2017 في
بالقرب من البرلمان بالطبع يعني
عندما تشاهد يعني هذا
العدد الهائل من عناصر الشرطه واغلاق عدد
من الشوارع يعني ممكن
سته شوارع على الاقل بحسب بعض التقارير
ولربما يعني
هذا الاغلاق لسته شوا يؤثر على بقيه الطرق
المؤديه اليها وبالتالي هذا مع ما دفع
سلطات النقل فيها في المدينه بتعليق خدمات
التنقل سواء كان عبر الترام او عبر حافلات
النقل يعني
كل هذا يشير بان ربما يعني هذا الحديث
يعني يرقى الى مستوى مستوى حادث ارهابي
بالمقارنه بالحوادث الماضيه
حقيقه
الكل يريد معرفه المزيد من التفاصيل رغم
ان يعني هذا مر على هذا الحدث تقريبا
ساعتين منذ بدايته
بحسب تقرير هناك شخص ربما كان يتلقى
العلاج او على على على
احدى جوانب او احد جوانب الطرق
حاليا
كانت اشاهد بعض
العناصر ربما من عناصر مدنيه في في احدى
هذه الشوارع المغلقه وبالطبع الشرطه يعني
لا تستطيع ان ان ان تدلي باي تصريحات في
الوقت الحالي لكن لربما سيتم نشر بعض
المعلومات في وقت لاحق من اليوم التواجد
كثيف للشرطه
للدفاع المدني
عاده للدفاع المدني لكن بالنسبه
لسيارات الاسعاف سيارات الاسعاف ربما
عددها اقل بالمقارنه بعناصر
بالفعل الواحد بحسب نجاحي بعض التقارير او
الاوليه كانت هناك
اسعافات يتم تقديم اسعافات لشخص واحد فقط
لا ادري
ان كان هذا الشخص يعني في حاله خطره ام لا
لكن بالطبع
العمليه هي يعني عمليه كبيره وصفتها
الشرطه بان حادث كبير مما يعني انها ان
الحادث يرقى الى تعامل بعناصر بعناصر
للشرطه بعدد كبير بالاضافه بقيه خدمات
الطوارئ التي عاده تكون مرافقه لعناصر
الشرطه في هكذا حادث وخاصه عندما يكون
بمستوى يعني بمستوى خطير بهذا الحجم يعني
لا ادري كم عدد العناصر
المتواجدين حاليا في هذه المناطق يعني
عندما تقول اغلاق سته شوارع او الطرق
الرئيسيه في وسط المدينه هذا يشل حركه
التنقل ونحن في بدايه في بدايه
الدوام اليومي مما يعني ان ربما العديد من
هذه الشركات في وسط المدينه المحل
التجاريه ايضا في يعني مغلقه حاليا ولربما
ستظل مغلقه
لفترات عندما يتم يعني حسم هذا الحادث
ان كان ان كانت له اي دوافع يعني مريضه
وخاصه تلك المتعلقه بالارهاب هذا البلد
عان الكثير من العمليات الارهابيه
كان اسمائها واخرها يعني عام 2017 في
مدينه مانشستر
عندما فجر
يعني مواطن بريطانيه من اصل الليبي نفسه
في في حفل غناء
المغنيه الامريكيه اند جراندي وبالتالي
اليوم يعني هو مختلف تماما عن الحوادث
السابقه عاده ما تكون هذه الحوادث في يعني
في اماكن تجمهر يعني الناس ولكن عندما تقع
هذه الحادثه في الساعه السابعه والربع
يعني
هناك تساؤلات
لماذا وكيف ومن وان كانت
لمن وراء هذا الحادث له دوافع
تتعلق بالارهاب وخاصه وان يعني
البلد يعني
دائما ما يراجع مستوى التاهب الامني ويجري
العديد من التدريبات لعماقره وحتى من قبل
بعض
الشركات الكبرى الذين يشاركون في عمليات
لمواجهه يعني
عمليات ارهابيه يعني متوقعه لان مثلا في
بعض الاحيان مثل ما شاهدنا قبل ربما قبل
خمس او اربع سنوات عندما كان احد
المتهمين بالارهاب كان في دوره
تدريبيه
لازاله الفكر المتطرف من من منه
وخلال حضوره لاحد الجلسات دخل الى مبنى
وقامها يعني بطعم الناس وفي الاخير تم تم
رميه بالرصاص من من طرف الشرطه يعني مثل
هذه المباني الضخمه بحاجه الى عناصر
يعني
عناصر تراقب هذا المبنى مثل الحراس الذين
يتلقون تدريبات خاصه للتعامل مع هكذا
ربما يريدون جرائم معينه وبالتالي
ما تم
الابلاغ عنه اليوم حتى هذه اللحظه وان
حادث كبير تتعامل معه الشرط الشرطه وايضا
كل يعني الضباط خدمات الطوارئ يتعامل مع
هذا الحادث في محاوله لكشف المزيد عن
طبيعتهما اذا كانت لهذا الحديث دوافع
ارهابيه طيب مصطفى يعني مدينه نوتنهام
يعني عطفا على موقعها الجغرافي وتوزيعها
الديموغرافي ايضا وطبيعه قاطنيها من سكان
يعني هل هي مرشح ايضا مثل هذه الهجمات
يعني حقيقه
مدينه يعني
سكانها لا يتعدون تقريبا
340 الف نسمه يعني هي مدينه صغيره
بالمقارنه مع لندن مثلا او او
حتى او
لم يعني اخر يعني بالنسبه بالنسبه لي يعني
اخر
زياره لي يعني كانت لتغطيه جريمه جريمه
قتل
[موسيقى]
يعني بشابه مصريه
ان كنت تتذكرها يعني تم تم التعدي عليها
في وسط المدينه كانت يعني تستقل حافله وتم
التهجم عليها
وفي الاخير انتهت بالمستشفى لكن كان هناك
تقصير من قبل ومما ادى الى وفاتها في وقت
لاحق يعني هذه اخر اخر جليل ربما يعني
تابعتها وغطيتها من مدينه ولكن بهذا الحجم
حاليا هناك الكثير من التساؤلات حول
طبيعته طيب مصطفى
المعلومات حول ما يحدث الان في الاهم
مشاهدينا اذا هناك حاله استنفار شهدتها
مدينه نوتنهام البريطانيه اليوم الثلاثاء
فيما استنفرت الشرطه في لندن ايضا ضاربه
طوقا امليا ضخما وسط العاصمه فقد اغفرت
الطرقات في نوتنها وصل انجلترا بينما اعلت
ايضا الشرطه البريطانيه مشاهدينا ان
عناصرها يتعاملون مع حادث خطير مستمر في
المدينه بحسب وصفها بدورها ايضا مشاهدينا
افاده الشرطه في نوتنهام بتغيير في تغريده
على تويتر انه تم اغلاق سته طرق في
المدينه عند الساعه السادسه وسبع وخمسين
دقيقه بتوقيت كما طالبت المواطنين والسكان
بالابتعاد عن مكان الحادث فيما اعلن
الشبكه الترام انها اقفلت جميع عملياتها
حتى اشعار اخر بسبب هذا الحادث
دون مزيد من التفاصيل اظهرت ايضا مشاهدينا
مقاطع تم تداولها على وسائل التواصل
الاجتماعي الطرقات مقفله وسطاء انتشار
لسيارات الاسعاف والطوارئ والشرطه كما
نتابع ايضا في هذه الصور اوضحت ايضا
مراسله العربيه مشاهدينا ان الاستنفاره
الامنيه الحاصل يرقى الى مستوى التعامل مع
حادث ارهابي الا ان اي تفاصيل اخرى لم
تصدر بعد عن المراجع الرسميه حول الحادث
الغامض هذا وسطها مخاوفها وتاويلات ايضا
من محاوله تنفيذ هجمات ارهابيه ياتي هذا
الحادث مشاهدينا في توقيت مزدحم حيث يتوجه
الالاف من البريطانيين في مثل هذا الوقت
الى اعمالهم والى اشغالهم
عفوا انشاء الى ان بريطانيا مشاهدينا كانت
شهدت خلال السنوات الماضيه بعض الهجمات
الارهابيه وان كان بنسب اقل من فرنسا او
غيرها من البلدان الاوروبيه نسيب العديد
من هذه الهجمات مشاهدينا الى تنظيم داعش
والى غيره من التنظيمات الارهابيه
المتطرفه مشاهدينا من لندن معنا دكتور
فؤاد عبد الرزاق المتخصص في الشؤون
البريطانيه اهلا بك دكتور فؤاد برغم شخه
الاشعه المعلومات حتى هذه اللحظه لكن ما
الذي يمكن ان يحدث الان او نتوقع
وما اذا كانت ايضا توفرت لك معلومات عطفا
على متابعتك الاحداث في بريطانيا
مرحبا بحضرتك وفي الواقع يعني الشرطه هذه
المره يعني
حريصه جدا على عدم الاداء بتفاصيل كثيره
فيما عدا كما قلتم توجيه الانذارات نظرا
لان المكان يتسم بالحيويه فهو في شارع ضخم
بيغطي مساحه كبيره وايضا يقع امام
الكونسر رؤيه الكونسر
موسيقيه ضخمه وايضا كل المؤشرات تشير الى
وجود بالفعل حادث كبير عاده في مثل هذه
الامور شرطه يعني يعني تعطي معلومات بسيطه
ثم تقول انه ارهابي او غير ارهابي او
لعلاقه له بالارهات التريص في هذا اما هذه
المره فيبدو ان الحادث بالفعل كبير
والمساحه المغطاه والتي يعني اقفلتها قوات
الشرطه هي مساحه كبيره بما يشي بان كحادثا
كبيرا قد وقعوا يشيلون اليه الى وقوع يعني
حادثه كبيره بالنسبه لتوصيف الشرطه ايضا
شهود وجود يعني ضباط مسلحين او جنود
مسلحين في منطقه السوق القديمه
ولكن لا يوجد تاثيرات يعني بشكل كبير حتى
هذه اللحظه هناك سيارات المطافئ باعداء
كبيره جدا
وضرب يعني كوردون او طوق كبير بمحيط
بالشارع الرئيسي ميلتون ستري فهذه الامور
كلها تشيء بوقوع شيء ولكن ليس هناك
معلومات محدده ولا
وصفات كما تشير لكن يعني كيف يمكن ان يفهم
هذا التكتم من السلطات الامنيه هناك يعني
تحذير المواطنين من حادث بعينه ربما يكون
له ايضا ايجابيات بمعنى ان يكون هناك
المزيد من الحظر ان تؤخذ هذه التحذيرات
بجديه اكثر وربما يبقى المواطنون في
منازلهم او في مناطق اكثر امنا هذا
البريطانيه اصلا
ولكن الشرطه لوحدها هذه المره بالذات انها
يعني اصدرت التحذيرات وتحذيرات مشدده
وتشير الى الحادث بانه حادث كبير غير
معتاد ان تاتي الشرطه وتقول هذا الكلام
ولذا نقول ان الحادثه ربما يكون له ابعاد
خطيره وتحذيرات لم تاتي من فراغ عاده
الشرطه بروتين تتحفظ في هذا الامر ولكن
هذه المره ارى انها تحذيرات تتسم بالجديه
الشديده ونطاق
المفروض المضروب على المنطقه هو بحجم كبير
جدا ليس حادثا بسيطا بطبيعه الحال هذه
الاحداث طبعا او ما شابهها انتبه انها
ارهابيه ولا نعرف حتى الان حتى لا نقرب
الى النتائج يعني كانت تحدث في بعض اماكن
اخرى وفي مدن اخرى اثناء كونسر او حفل
موسيقي او خروج كما شاهدنا في الماضي وما
زال حتى التهابات مواجهه الان في مثل هذه
القضايا في المدن اخرى لكن هذه المره يعني
او نوتيجه لم تذكر من قبل في كثير من
الامور منذ الخلافه لمدن اخرى مثل
قليل الذي اشار الى ان ربما ان اخر
حدث ارهابي طردت له بريطانيا في 2017 في
مانشستر وهذا ايضا يصعب بالتساؤل يعني هذه
هذه فتره زمنيه
مداها سته سنوات او خمس سنوات تقريبا هل
بريطانيا مرشحه لمثل هذه الاعمال التي
توصف ايضا بالارهابي اذا ما اتاكد ان هذا
الحادث هو فعلا ارهابي لماذا تستهدف في
هذا التوقيت
قريبه جدا كانت وحتى كانت هناك المتهم
الليبي وشقيقه ووعظهم مسجونين حتى الان
ايضا
هذه امور موجوده واعاده قريب وليس كبير
الذي وقع امام البرلمان هذه امور قريبه
جدا لم تكن بهذا المدى الثانوي الكبير
حدثت وهو مرشحه للحدوث والغريب ان احيانا
يقال ان هذا الشخص مثلا لم يكن على رادار
الشرطه باعتبار تنشيط ارهابي اشياء كثيره
حتى لا تداء على مثلا احد اعضاء البرلمان
الكبار في من قبل صومالي الجنسيه فهذه
الامور تحدث وبالطبع مرشحه ولكن هذا يعتمد
كله على مدى النشاط الاستخباراتي ومتابعه
هؤلاء الناس هذه الامور تحدث وليست مست
ويمكن ان تحدث ومن هنا ارى ان قلق الشرطه
هذه المره يزيد كثيرا عن الامور المعتاده
الروتينيه التي عاده ما تطول ان
طابع التحفظ هنا الان ليس التحول ولكن رغم
ذلك ليس هناك قفزا
ليس هناك قفز للاستنتاج على انه حادث
ارهابي او غير ارهابي ولكن المؤشرات تشير
الى وقوع حادث خطير ماذا خطورته لو كان
حديثا مثلا حريقه او شيء من هذا القبيل
كان قالوا ولكن يبدو ان هناك شيئا اكبر من
مجرد حادث عربي
بمعنى انه حادث خطير حسب روايه الشرطه
ماذا عن بقيه المدن فقط عن نوتنهام لكن
ماذا عن لندن بقيه المدن البريطانيه هل
رشح ما يفيد بان هناك امنيه فيها ربما
هروب هل يمكن ان تتعرض ايضا لحوادث مشابهه
في مثل هذا التوقيت
كثيره مثل مانشستر
تكون عامه اذا كان الحاجز له ابعاد اكبر
من ذلك لكن لم يعني
لم تنطق الجراث الخطر مدن اخرى وتمتد الى
ذلك وعاده هذا لا يمكن ان يحدث يعني ان
يحدث كل الحوادث وقت واحد غير غير قائد في
الوقت الحالي الشرطه بطبيعه الحال خساره
جهدها في استيعاب الحاجز بالذات ولكن كما
قلت ما يصدر عن الشرطه هو اكبر مما كان
متوقعا منها في مثل هذه الامور التي
استحفظ فيها الى هذا التحفظ اعتقد مساله
وقت فقط الحين الاعلان عن ابعاد هذا
الحادث الامر لاحتوائه الان تحذير الناس
عد المنطقه صارت طوق امن كبير على مساحه
كبيره من هذه الدائره لانها تقع بقرب
اماكن حيويه وفي شوارع حيويه عاده ما تكون
مزدحمه فهنا هو مجال القلق قبل الصدور
اصدار تصريحات عن طبيعه الحارس وما حاجه
بالضبط
على الاحتياطات الامنيه للشرطه ليس
بالضروره ان يكون هذا الحل لهم امتداد في
مدن اخرى ولكن رغم هذه التحضيرات التي
اشرت اليها الدكتور فؤاد لكن نتابع هذه
الصور حركه للمواطنين يعني في هذه المناطق
تحديدا يعني هذا عن بقيه المدينه
هل تؤخذ تحذيرات الشرطه بالجديه اللازمه
بقبل المواطنين سواء في بريطانيا
هام تحديدا
الشديد اصلا الشرطه لا تسمح بالاقتراب من
هذا الطوق الذي يفرض وهناك حاله من الوعي
بين الجمهور هناك يعني اجتماع
نعم طيب دكتور فؤاد بالبقاء معي ساعود
اليكم من جد في سياق متابعتها لهذه
الاحداث في نوتنهام وايضا مشاهدينا حاله
استنفار كما تابعنا وكما نتابع الان شهد
مدينه نوتنهام البريطانيه اليوم الثلاثاء
كما نتابع في هذه الصور لانتشار قوات
الامن وقوات الحمايه ايضا المتواجده في
هذا المكان وسط توقيت الامني يفرض على هذه
المنطقه اذا مشاهدينا استنفرت الشرطه في
لندن ايضا وضرب الطوقا امنيا ضخما وسط
العاصمه فقد اقفلت الطرقات كما نتابع الان
في نوتنهام وسطه انجلترا بينما اعلنت ان
عناصرها
يتعاملون مع حادث خطير مستمر في المدينه
الشرطه ايضا مشاهدينا افادت بتغريره على
تويتر انه تم اغلاق سته طرق في المدينه
عند الساعه السادسه والسبع وخمسين بتوقيت
جرينتش الشرطه ايضا مشاهدينا في هام طالبت
المواطنين والسكان بالابتعاد عن مكان
الحادث واعلنت ايضا مشاهدينا شبكه الترام
انها اقفلت عملياتها حتى اشعار اخر بسبب
هذا الحادثنا مزيد من التفاصيل نتابع
مشاهدينا اذا هذه الصور
وفيها سيارات الاسعاف والاطفاء والاجهزه
الامنيه رفيعه المستوى الموجوده في
نوتنهام التي تشارك ايضا في
فرض طوق امني على هذه المنطقه بسبب حادث
تتكتم حتى الان الشرطه البريطانيه على
طبيعته لكنها طالبت كما تابعنا واكدنا
طلبه المواطنين
التواجد في مناطق غير امنه المشاهدين هذه
الصور مباشره ايضا من نوتنهام التي نتابع
فيها هذه الاحداث التي تتكتم الشرطه
البريطانيه عليها لكنها تؤكد انها لا تزال
تتعامل مع خطر امني مستمر مراسل العربيه
مشاهدين اكد قبل قليل استحضار اجهزه امنيه
متخصصه لوسط نوتنهام للتعامل مع هذا الحدث
الامني الخطير بحسب وصفه الشرطه
البريطانيه
وقال ايضا واساءه العربيه ان الاستنفار
الامني هام يرقى الى مستوى التعامل مع
حادث ارهابي واضاف ايضا ان الشرطه
البريطانيه تطالب تفادي او تطالب تفادي
الذهاب الى وسط سوناتنهام حتى اشعار اخر
المراسل العربيه ايضا مشاهدين اقد ان اكد
ان قوات بريطانيه مسلحه موجوده على الارض
في نوتنهام وان الاستنفار الامني او وسط
نوتنهام الى مستوى التعامل مع حادث ارهابي
كما ان الطوق الامني في نتنهام مستمر
مشاهدينا منذ ساعات والشرطه البريطانيه
تتكتم على السبب حتى هذه اللحظه مناطق وسط
توتنهام ايضا مشاهدينا اصبحت معطله
بالكامل بسبب هذا الطوق الامني الذي تتكتم
الشرطه البريطانيه على اسباب فرضه في هذا
التوقيت وهناك حضور كبير للسيارات الاسعاف
والاطفاء والاجهزه الامنيه ايضا رفيعه
المستوى في النوتنهام
الان مشاهدينا بلندن معنا الكاتب الصحفي
محمد شباره اهلا بك سيد محمد وما هي
قراءتك الى ما يحدث الان في نطنها
يعني
المظاهر او المعلومات الاوليه التي تفشي
عنها الشرطه هو ان هناك تهديد كبير كما
جاء في كلامكم ووسطكم ولكن لا يبدو ان
الامر هو خطير للغايه بشكل كبير لان الصور
الاوليه الوارده من نطهم تشير الى انه
ربما كان هناك جريمه ما هناك اعتداء امني
ذو طبيعه
[موسيقى]
جاده ارهابيه او او ان هناك ربما طرد ما
قد تم تركه في مكان ما يعني كل هذه امور
واحتمالات نحن يعني نقولها الان ولكن بيان
الشرطه وحده ثابث بهذا الامر ولكن الصور
الاوليه التي تريدنا من ونشاهدها منهم
تفيد الى ان مستوى هذا
التهم السيطره عليه ان صح التعبير وان
قوات الشرطه تتعامل مع هذا الخطر اما ما
هو معلوم ان بريطانيا هذه الايام هناك
طبعا درجات التاهب في البلاد درجه التاهب
الحاليه في البلا
د هي منخفضه للغايه ان اي انه ليس لدى
الاجهزه الامنيه اجهزه الاستخبارات
الداخليه البريطانيه اي معلومات عن
ما يعرف
باجواء والاوساط الاستخباراتيه بان هناك
ته
ديد ادى من قبل جماعات متطرفه الى اليمين
او الى
التطرف الاسلامي مثلا
تهدد ارجاء بريطانيا حاليا فمستوى هذا
الخطر ومنذ اشهر طويله هو منخفض للغايه
ولذلك يعني من المفاجاه اليوم ان نتابع ما
جرى
وبانتظار ان نعرف ماهيه هذا التهديد ولكن
الواضح من الصور الاوليه ان الناس حول
الطوق الامني يتابعون اعمالهم كالمعتاد
وان كانت تعطلت اعمال البعض خصوصا وان
المنطقه هي في وسط الهام في شمال انجلترا
هو كما تفضلت انهم المفاجئ حدوث هذا
الحادث في هذا التوقيت لكن ايضا هناك من
يرى انه من مفاجئ استهداف النوتنهام
تحديدا يعني هل من خصوصيه تميز هذه
المدينه حتى تكون مسرحا لحادث امني خطير
بهذا الشكل تتكتم الشرطه البريطانيه على
تفاصيله حتى اللحظه
كل الاحتمالات استاذي العزيز وارده لكن
يعني من الصعب التكهن ولا يجب التكهن
باحتمالات ما جرى تحديدا
هي مدينه في وسط انجلترا مثل مثلها مثل
المدن لندن ومانشستر وبيراميدز تقطنها
يعني جماعات عرقيه متنوعه هي خليط عرقي
وان كان في يعني بين سكانها عدد كبير ايضا
من الجليات المسلمه من اصول اسيويه
ويعيشون يعني الى يعني هذا هو النسيج
الاجتماعي الموجود في اغلب المدن
البريطانيه كانت في الماضي ربما مسرحا
لبعض
الاحداث
المتطرفه او العمليات الشرطه للقبض على
بعض
المتطرفين الذين ينمون القيام ببعض
الاعمال من هذه الجهه التطرف اليميني او
التطرف الاسلامي ولكن عموما انها مدينه
هادئه مثلها مثل المدن البريطانيه الاخرى
ولكن من المؤكد ان هناك ما يدعو الشرطه
لضرب هذا الطوق وحدث اليوم
وعاده لا تتخذ الشرطه مثل هذه الاجراءات
لولا ان لديها من الادله ما يدعوها لضرب
هذا الطوق الامنيه الواسع حفاظا على سلامه
المواطنين والقاتنين لم نسمع انها قامت
باجلاء اي من المواطنين في المناطق
المجاوره حتى الان ولكن كما تفضلتم ايضا
في مقدمتكم ان هناك كافه اجهزه الشرطه
وايضا تساندها اجهزه الاطفاء والاسعاف وهي
متاهبه وايضا وصول تعزيزات امنيه متخصصه
من قوات الشرطه
التعامل مع هذا التهديد الامني الذي ان دل
على شيء يدل ربما على طرد مشبوه او ربما
ان هناك
كان في طور الاعداد
لوقوع او وقعت جريمه عاليه على درجه عاليه
من الاهميه في تلك المنطقه ولكن كل
المؤشرات الان تشير الى ان الهدوء يسود
وتحقيقات الشرطه وعمل الشرطه مستمر فيها
طيب وانت السيد محمد انا متواجد في لندن
يعني هل شعرتم او هناك ما يشيء بتحركات
امنيه وارتداد او تحذيرات ربما من شيء ما
يحدث هل يقتصر فقط ام من هناك مناطق اخرى
في الداخل البريطاني ايضا معرضه
لمريطانيا وفق المعلومات الاستخباراتيه
الاوليه التي لديها اي هذه هي السلطات
الامنيه المختصه فانه يرفع مستوى التهديد
وان طبعا حراسات المرافق حراسات ومتابعه
الامن الوطني في اكثر من مدينه ومدن يتم
تعزيزه ولكن ليس بالضروره ان تبدو مظاهره
بشكل واضح للمواطن العادي في هذه المرحله
بالذات قبل ان يتكشف نوع هذا الخطر او
مدى حجمه وتاثيره وامتداده ولكن طبعا
اجهزه الامن وهو اجراء روتيني اذا حدث ما
يدعو ما يعتبر تحديدا يعني حقيقيا للامن
في احدى المناطق فانه يستوجب على اجهزه
الامن في كافه المقاطعات والاقاليم والمدن
ان تقوم ايضا اتخاذ الاجراءات
والمعلومات الاوليه الان يبدو انها جريمه
ما اعتقال شخص بعد بعدما بعد العثور على
ثلاثه قتله في نوتنهام هذه المعلومات
الاوليه التي تاتينا تباعا من مصادر
اعلاميه في الوقت الحالي ليست من مصادر
الشرطه ولكن على ما يبدو انها
حادث ذو جانب جرمي في هذه المرحله بالذات
ولا ادري ان كان يمكن يعني القول انه ليس
له تداعيات او خلفيات
امنيه حقيقيه مثل الارهاب او غيرها حاليا
تقول يعني معلومات امنيه اوليه معلومات
اعلاميه اوليه ان هناك شخص اعتقل بعد
العثور على ثلاثه قتله في مدينه مقيم تفضل
بقاع سيد محمد
مصطفى زارو مصطفى ما الجديد لديك هو ما
الذي اعلنت عنه الشرطه بريطانيه تحديدا
بحس
[موسيقى]
ربما انها تعرضت لطلقتين رصاص بحسب بحسب
هذا هذا الشاهد وهناك ايضا اثر للقص
اص زجاج
المركبه التي كان يستقلها هذا الشخص لكن
الان وان الشرطه الان تؤكد الشرطه
به بارتكاب جريمه قتل بعد قتل ثلاثه اشخاص
في مدينه
وتقول يعني الشرطه بان
تقريبا بعد الساعه الرابعه بتوقيت لندن
يعني بتوقيت بريطاني يعني الساعه الثالثه
غرينتش
تم العثور على جثثين في في احد شوارع
المدينه يعني هذا هذا هو يعني
التصريح الرسمي او البيان الرسمي من قبل
الشرطه تؤكد اعتقال شخص على خلفيه ارتكابه
جريمه قتل بحق شخصين على على الاقل يعني
انا يعني وانا اشاهد هذا البيان اريد يعني
ان اترجمه فوريا لكن بالطبع يعني يعني هذا
الحادث الكبير هو ليس ارهابيا ولكن جريمه
يتم التعامل معها كانها جريمه قتل بحق على
الاقل شخصين بالاضافه الى ان مرتكبه هذه
الجريمه اعتقل وتم صعقه بمسدس صاعق من قبل
الشرطه مما يعني ان هذا الشخص
لا يزال على قيد الحياه سيتم يعني التحقيق
معه على حول خلفيه هذا الحادث الاجرامي
الذي وقع في وقت مبكرا من صباح اليوم في
مدينه نوتينغام هذه المدينه الهادئه التي
اسمع الكثير عن اعمال الجرائم الضخمه
الاستعاده ما نشاهدها في مدن كبرى مثل
لندن ومانشستر
هذه المدينه اليوم استفقت على وقع
حادث خطير قتل على الاقل شخصين حاليا
واعتقال المجتمع به بارتكاب هذه الجريمه
جريمه القتل
يفترض ان يتم ان يكون هناك تصريح رسمي
يعني التلفزيوني حول هذا الحادث الكبير
ولربما سيتم نشر هذه التصريحات في وقت
لاحق من قبل وكالات
وكالات يعني
الوكالات الاعلاميه
في في المملكه المتحده
الاخبار حقيقه يعني كان التساؤلات كثيره
حول طبيعه هذا الحادث الكبير وتواجد
الكثيف لعناصر الشرطه وايضا الطوارئ التي
عاده ما نشاهدها في احداث يعني خطيره بهذا
الحجم لكن لكن الان وان تم اعتقال هذا
الشخص الذي قتل بعد قتله ثلاثه اشخاص الان
ثلاثه اشخاص قتلوا من طرف مشتبه به
اعتقلته الشرطه وساعقته وربما بحسب شاهد
عيان انه سمع الطلقات رصاص وهناك اثر
لطلقتين على الاقل
طلقتين على سياره هذا المجتبى به كان هناك
ايضا شوهد شوهدت حقيبه حقيبه على الارض
ومركبته البيضاء يعني
بجانب هذه هذه الحقيبه بالاضافه الى هذا
الشخص كان على الرصيف مكبل اليدين بعد
ساقه
وبه الى مخفر للشرطه للتحقيق معه حول قتله
ثلاثه اشخاص في مدينه نوطغم في المذكره
تؤكد ايضا ان الشخص المعتقل يبلغ من العمر
واحد وثلاثين عاما لكن
الشوط ايضا سوف تقول نتعامل مع ثلاثه
حوادث امنيه متزامنه في نوتنهام منذ
الرابعه فجرا لكن مصطفى مع توضح او بدايه
توضح ملابسات هذا الحدث الامني في نوتنهام
هل ما زالت الاجراءات الاحترازيه والامنيه
مستمره فيها تلك المنطقه
بعض الوقت لاعاده فتح الطرقات بمجرد
انتهاء فريق تحقيق الجنائي لاخذ الادله من
عين المكان
لا ادري ان كان يعني
لهؤلاء الثلاثه الذين قتلوا من قبل هذا
المشتبه
ان كانوا ربما مثلا في في احد
النوادي الليليه او او ما شابه ذلك لان
الحادثه هي تقريبا في يعني الساعه الثالثه
فجرا بتوقيت غرينتش وهذا يعني انه
ربما هذا الشخص له يعني يعرف او له معرفه
بهؤلاء الذين نفذ بحقهم جريمه القتل
بالطبع التحقيقات لا تزال جاريه لمعرفه
ملابسات هذه الجريمه وايضا اعاده
ركز المدينه
[موسيقى]
مصطفى هذه الصور التي
تنقل من موقع
الهجوم في نوتنهام وموقع الحادث في
نوتنهام والشرطه البريطانيه تقول ان
التحقيقات لا تزال في مراحيلها الاولى وان
التحقيقات ما زالت مستمره وتقول ايضا
الشرطه بريطانيه اننا نتعامل مع ثلاثه
حوادث امنيه متزامنه في نوتنهام منذ
الرابعه فجرا وشرطه بريطانيا ايضا
مشاهدينا تقول ان الشخص المعتقل في
توتنهام عمره 31 عام مشاهدينا نتابع هذه
الصور ايضا المتداوله
للطلقات رصاص التي
اصابت او اطاله سياره المشتبه به اذا هذه
الصور مشاهدينا هي صور متداوله لسياره
المشتبه به ويبدو عليها اثار
الرصاص في نوتينغهام نذكر المشاهدين بان
الشرطه بريطانيه تقول ان التحقيق ات في
المدينه لا تزال في مراحلها
الاولى وانها اعتقدت حتى الان شخصا يبلغ
من عمر 31 عاما وهناك جثث لثلاثه قتل لا
عثر عليهم في النوتنهام الشرطه تؤكد انها
ما تزال تتعامل مع خطر امني في هذه
المدينه
ونتابع معكم ايضا انتشار لقوات الشرطه هذه
الصور المباشره من توتنهام للانتشار قوات
الشرطه في هذا في هذه المنطقه وفرض الطوخ
الامنيه عقب الحديث عن حادث امني تقول
الشرطه انه نجم عن او نتج عنه ثلاثه قتله
حتى الان واعتقال مشتبه به وتابعنا قبل
ايضا صوره المشاهدين للسياره المشتبه به
وتبدو عليها اثار الرصاصة مصطفى عد اليكم
كنت تسمعني الان نحن بانتظار ربما مؤتمر
صحفي او توضيحات اكثر من الشرطه في
الساعات المقبله اليس كذلك
حسب حسب ما تابعت بانه تم ابلاغ وزيره
الداخليه بما يجري في في المدينه من قبل
الشرطه ولربما ستكون كلمه
للمسؤول عن الشرطه في مدينه
للكشف عن مزيد حول هذه الحادثه التي وسطها
الشرطه بالخطيره واعطاء المزيد من
التفاصيل لكن بالطبع يعني
نوايا هذا الشخص وعمليه كيف تم قتل هؤلاء
الضحايا الثلاثه سواء كان يعني معرفه يعني
الاداه التي استخدمها سواء كانت يعني مسدس
او او
نتابع معك ومع الساده المشاهدين هذه الصور
ايضا المتداوله
للشرطه البريطانيه التي تلقي القبضه في
بحسب هذه الصوره على على مشتبه به في هذا
الحادث الامني الذي ادى الى مقتل ثلاثه
اشخاص ينتجهم الى هذه الصور متداوله
مشاهدين لعناصر من الشرطه البريطانيه
اثناء القائها القبض على المشتبه به في
هذا الحادث الامني في النوتنهام
البريطانيه التي تقول الشرطه البريطانيه
فيها ان التحقيقات لا تزال في مراحلها
الاولى وانها تتعامل مع ثلاثه حوادث امنيه
متزامنه في مدينه نوتنهام منذ الرابعه
فجرا تقول ايضا الشرطه البريطانيه ان هذا
الشخص المعتقل الذي نتابع صور اعتقاله على
هذه المشاهد المتداوله يبلغ من العمر واحد
وثلاثين عاما واكدت الشرطه البريطانيه
ايضا ان فريق التحقيق لا يزال يعمل في
موقع الحادث لمعرفه ما جرى في نوتنهام
ولكن قبل ذلك مشاهدينا انها
عثرت على جثث ثلاثه قتلى في مدينه نوتنهام
وانها لا تتسهل تتعامل مع خطر امني مستمر
اعود اليك مصطفى مره اخرى تفضل
يعني حقيقه احنا نحن الان بانتظار
التقرير الرسمي من قبل الشرطه وان كان
هناك بيان اولي
للكشف عن ان ثلاثه اشخاص قتلوا في مدينه
في مدينه نوتين وايضا هناك مصابون ايضا في
في مستشفى المدينه بالاضافه الى اعتقال
مشتبه به ربما ارتكب هذه الجريمه بعد ان
تم طاقه وكانت هناك طلقات رصاص مثلما ذكرت
ربما يعني وصلتكم الصور الان هذا الاثر
على هذه السياره البيضاء التي ربما كان
يستقلها هذا الشخص هل يستخدم هذه السياره
لقتل هؤلاء هل هل حاول
او حتى استخدم استخدم يعني
مسدس لقتل هؤلاء واصابه واصابه اخرين
بالطبع ربما سنعرف المزيد عنها على الاقل
ان هذا الشخص يعني محتجز الان يبلغ من
العمر كما ذكرت الشرطه 31 عاما
ايضا ربما سنعرف عن اصابات
اخرين ان كان خطيره ام لا وايضا دوافع هذا
الشخص يعني سبب يعني ارتكابه هذه الجريمه
هل هناك يعني
علاقات شخصيه مع هؤلاء مشاكل بينهما
هناك يعني مثلا بالنسبه لا ادري بالنسبه
اعرف بان في لندن مثلا هناك عصابات يعني
كل عصابه
[موسيقى]
اماكن تسيطر على العصابه اخرى يكون هناك
صراع بين هذه العصابات وبالتالي لا ندري
طبيعه طبيعه هذه الحادثه الخطيره التي
عنها الشرطه في مدينه نوتنغام ولكن ربما
ست
ما جرى في ايضا طيب مصطفى بالنسبه لما
نشاهده الانمي صور ايضا هناك حركه شبه
طبيعيه في بعض المناطق حول حائض الطوق
الامني تبدو الطبيعيه الى حد ما يعني هل
هذا هو الواقي بحسب ما تفرقه المعلومات هل
يطمئن سكان المدينه وبداوا في مزاوله
اعمالهم اليوميه والتوجه ربما الى اعمالهم
في هذه اللحظات
الشرطه تحاول باسرع يعني قدر الامكان ان
تعيد مركز المدينه الى العمل مجددا لكن لا
تزال هناك يعني
اشرطه تغلق شوارع
محدده ربما القريبه جدا من هذا الحدث ولا
ندري ايضا يعني هل هذا الحديث تم ارتكابه
في عدد من الشوارع ام شارع واحد فقط يعني
الكثير من من التساؤلات يعني يطرحها الناس
[موسيقى]
عندما تبقى سته شوارع هل هذه شوارع شهدت
كلها حوادث ام ان الحادثه الخطيره شملت
حادث يعني شملت شارع
عن ثلاثه حوادث مصطفى ليس كذلك وليس حادثا
واحدا
[ضحك]
[موسيقى]
الحصول على على المدينه التفاصيل على
الاقل من خلال البيان التي نشرته الشرطه
لكن يعني عندما
في عدد من الشوارع ربما من المستبعد ان
يكون في مكان واحد واغلاق سته شوارع محيطه
بهذا الحادث يعني هذا يعني
تحليل مبدئي حول يعني اين وقعت هذه
الجريمه القتل وايضا اصابه الاخرين يعني
هناك هناك اصابات لا ندري مدى حجم او
خطوره هذه الاصابه هؤلاء في هذه الحادثه
ولكن لا تزال شوارع مغلقه في مدينه في
مدينه الناتجان هناك بعض الماره
اشاهدهم
على على الشاشه حاليا ولكن ربما هذا
التحرك محدود بانتظار لكن المناطق
اخرى يعني
مفتوحه وربما ستزيد حركه التنقل او حركه
هؤلاء بمجرد معك بهذا القدر في هذه الساعه
الاخباريه لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار
والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات
والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في
قناتنا على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات